Is a smart wristwatch really the next frontier for Apple?
The New York Times reported over the weekend that Apple...
...was experimenting with a so-called iWatch, banking on the company's curved glass technology...
...to deliver an iOS operated, wearable mini computer.
Noting the place of such device is in James Bond and comic book lore.
Reports said that advances in easily bendable Willow glass...
...had helped bring the product closer than ever to reality.
A Chinese gadget blog had previously reported on rumors...
...that Apple plans to create a wristwatch computer with Bluetooth and a 1.5-inch display.
The new reports caution that there was no timeline for the watches...
...or even a guarantee they would ever make it to the market.
Google, meanwhile, is forging ahead with computers wearable as glasses,...
...which it hopes to account for three percent of its revenue by 2015.